Something truly stunning and disgusting happened
last night and I'm disgusted by it.
I'm, I'm, I don't, I'm having trouble even
putting my thoughts together because it is
so vile and disgusting. Last night I was planning
to stream live commentary on the CNN debate.
The first night of it, as I always do, I started
the stream 15 minutes before the event. At
the time that the debate itself started, our
channel had 10,000 live viewers and climbing
very, very quickly. Lots of people wanted
to watch my commentary on the debate, participate
in the live shows that we do around big political
events. At two minutes past the hour, 8:02
PM Eastern, CNN shut us down and they shut
us down. Hard issuing what's called a hard
copyright strike to our youtube channel. In
addition to ending the stream on the screen
for you now is the takedown notice. You will
notice at the bottom left that it says manually
detected. This means it was not an algorithm
that caught us inadvertently as someone stealing
their content, but this was a person whose
name I've blurred out who personally at CNN
found our stream and went out of their way
to get us a copyright strike.
You will notice in the lower right of the
screen it says strike expires October 28 2019
this means we are banned from all live streaming
on Youtube for 90 days. This is a disaster
and this was optional. Okay. There's a mechanism
for CNN to just take the ad revenue from our
stream but not shut it down. This is what
NBC was doing the last debate to channels
of our size that are not stealing content.
We have established audiences, this is fair
use. Audiences want to hear our commentary
and we are providing something of value. We
are not just repeating a stream and adding
nothing. CNN could have chosen to put a third
party claim on our video and allow the stream
to continue, but they take the ad revenue
and I would have been fine for that. People
support our streams with super chats and memberships
and the like, but instead they do this.
They choose to jeopardize our account for
three months and then if you think this is
just okay, not that crazy, then it gets even
more disgusting. The vice president and spokesperson
for CNN worldwide attacked me on Twitter,
implying that we are some kind of fraudulent
pirating operation. Take a look at this insanity
tweeting. Of course you can't pirate content.
We spent millions and millions to produce,
and the irony of this is amazing. First of
all, you've spent millions and millions to
produce one event that tells you the scale
and size of your operation. Why do you care
about an independent channel like mine doing
live about your event? If this is the scale
at which you're operating, which it is, how
does what I'm doing even rank high enough
to number one trigger somebody to manually
seek me out and shut me down? And number two,
why are you even tweeting at me?
You're the vice president of a department
of CNN, and of course, using the word pirating
is so dismissive. Like I get it. I'm not CNN,
but this is a show that's in youtube is one
or two top percent. We're professionally produced.
We have an audience of tens of thousands of
people who are waiting for my analysis. Pirating
implies implies I'm a guy in a basement. Rebroadcasting
a feed of the debate alone, not creating programming
with live callers and analysis and something
of value and then other CNN flunkies jump
right in. Liking this guy's tweets, a Hong
Kong based CNN journalist, CNN, his communications
director, just loving, loving how CNN is treating
us and this part is maybe the craziest. Okay.
I don't know if it relates to this copyright
strike. You might've noticed that on Youtube
we've had this join button where you can become
a youtube member for a few bucks a month.
We had gotten up to almost a thousand of those
youtube members this morning. All thousand
of those are gone. I don't know if it's a
glitch. I've contacted youtube. I've told
them, listen, we got a copyright strike. I
looked at our member list on youtube and it
went from almost a thousand to zero. Is this
a glitch or have we really lost the thousand
members on Youtube? We spent a year building
up, so this is bad. Sadly, they basically
want my tools for fighting this are very limited.
We've submitted a counter claim which takes
10 business days to be reviewed by youtube
and then after two weeks of that they send
it to CNN and CNN has another month and they
can simply reject my counterclaim. I've contacted
my Youtube Rep, I've contacted the youtube
Twitter account so far, no dice, so this is
very, very bad for us. Live streams generate
revenue for us.
We were planning on doing maybe half a dozen
major ones in the next three months around
debates and other political events. One bit
of success. I did go over to twitch last night.
I did my first stream on twitch and it went
pretty well, so first and foremost, follow
us on twitch at twitch.tv/david Pacman. We
will try to stream tonight over there commentary
commentary right at 7:45 PM eastern time and
most importantly, don't let them win. Okay?
They take their millions and millions like
this guy told me and they use it to shut down.
People like me, I hope that you will support
us directly. I'm asking for you to do that.
You can get a membership on our website@joinpacman.com
takes under a minute. Really supports the
work that we're doing, helps us fight this
type of stuff. Or you can throw us a pledge
of as little as a dollar a month on Patrion
at patrion.com/david Pakman show. It's bad
out there. It's bad. Make sure you're following
me on twitch at dot e
v Slash David Pakman. Hope to see you there
tonight